bonsoir monsieur le ministre vous
n'échapperez pas ce soir aux questions
sur le bilan des deux ans de pouvoir de
la gauche deux ans qui en ce qui vous
concerne se partage en deux mi-temps
d'égal durer un an comme secrétaire
général de l'elysée où vous avez eu
l'accès à tous les grands dossiers
internationaux
un an comme ministre des affaires
sociales et de la solidarité
c'est à dire un peu à votre corps
défendant le ministre du malaise social
actuel alors l'une des questions que les
français se posent et à laquelle vous
serez certainement invités à répondre ce
soir est la suivante est ce que la
justice sociale a fait des progrès
depuis l'arrivée de la gauche au pouvoir
en france
et si oui quel progrès alors vous ne
direz quel analyse vous fait de la
montée du mécontentement que l'on
constate ici et là et qui s'est tenu
encore à provoquer des incidents à paris
et vous qui est précisément ministre de
la solidarité monsieur vergoz voix vous
nous direz si cette belle idée de la
solidarité nationale n'est pas remise en
cause à la fois dans les appels à la
lutte des classes de certains de vos
amis politiques et par la montée des
égoïsmes des corporations et la tendance
des différents groupes à considérer
chacun qu'il est le plus touché par la
crise et par la politique de rigueur
alors avant de vous livrer aux questions
d'alain duhamel d'antenne 2 puis de
philippe vasseur du nouveau journal et
d'albert du roi d'antenne 2 nous allons
faire un détour par svp où anita bensaïd
et philippe harrouard ont déjà en main
les premières questions des
téléspectateurs philippe harrouard oui
il y a déjà beaucoup de questions et le
standard est bloqué depuis 20 heures il
faut un peu patienter quand vous nous
appelez ce deuxième constatation dans
ses nombreuses questions on vous appelle
très souvent monsieur le premier
ministre
peut-être pourrez-vous nous répondre là
dessus enfin beaucoup de téléspectateurs
veulent savoir qui êtes vous monsieur
bérégovoy et l'un d'entre eux qui est
commerçant instinct nous dit même
qu'elle est votre niveau intellectuel
qu'avez-vous fait par le passé et
quelles sont vos bagages alors vous
répondre à cette question je crois que
c'est une bonne entrée en matière de
vous présenter vous même écoutez le
c'est vrai que j'ai commencé à
travailler jeune a 16 ans à 15 ans et
demi et je j'ai mon brevet élémentaire
et je me suis formé
moi même j'ai eu un peu de chance dans
ma vie d'abord aux chemins de fer et
ensuite à gaz de france
j'ai rencontré des amis qui l'ont aidé
et j'ai été syndicaliste et c'est une
école de la vie très intéressante pour
parler avec les patrons pour discuter
avec les supérieurs hiérarchiques pour
défendre ses camarades il faut
travailler connaître les dossiers et
être capable d'expliquer dans un langage
aussi claire que possible les
revendications exprimées
ça m'a beaucoup pdg tout de même et l
université je suis allé à l'âge de 30
ans c'était à strasbourg l'institut du
travail et c'est là que j'ai appris ce
qu'était l'enseignement supérieur bref
j'ai appris à prendre des notes et
depuis se bat pas mal aidé eh bien
monsieur liste première question alors
alain duhamel verrines sa place et avec
lequel vous allez être en face à face
pendant un quart d'heure alain duhamel
vous disiez à l'instant à françois henri
de virieu que
vous aviez été syndicaliste qui est
syndicaliste à quel syndicat j'ai été
syndicaliste à force ouvrière et j'ai
été syndicaliste à la cfdt ensuite bon
je n'aurais ça parce que comme ça
intéresse les téléspectateurs puisqu'ils
veulent savoir qui vous êtes et puis
quand on est mise affaires sociales
c'est intéressant il ya un certain temps
que je ne milite plus dans le
syndicalisme puisque j'ai exercé des
responsabilités au parti socialiste et
je considère que les partis politiques
doivent respecter l'indépendance des
syndicats
et j'ai la chance d'entretenir avec la
plupart des responsables syndicaux tout
de même de bons rapports je les connais
depuis longtemps
on s'apprécie on se dispute parfois mais
on trouve souvent le chemin du dialogue
alors justement à propos de dialogue en
regardant le journal télévisé tout à
l'heure on voyait pierre mauroy dans une
déclaration un petit peu solennel disait
qu'à la fois il fallait être vis-à-vis
des étudiants un homme de dialogue et en
même temps qu'il fallait faire respecter
l'ordre républicain
alors le premier ministre a dit en
passant que il n'était pas très question
de repousser comme le demandent les
étudiants l'examen la discussion du
projet de loi sur l'enseignement
supérieur qui était l'origine de toutes
ces grèves à l'automne comme le veulent
les étudiants alors qu'est ce que ça
peut être d'abord qu'un dialogue avec
des étudiants qui souhaitent qu'on
repousse un projet de loi à l'automne
pour pouvoir s'exprimer et discuter si
on ne pousse pas à l'automne les
étudiants peuvent s'exprimer ils le font
actuellement
ils peuvent saisir les parlementaires de
leurs revendications
et c'est justement l'occasion au
parlement où le ministre de l'éducation
nationale alain savary présentera son
projet de loi de discuter demander de
corriger
je crois qu'il faut voir les choses de
cette manière et sans passion par contre
il ya derrière les mouvements étudiants
actuels voilà tout de même
des fauteurs de désordre bon que le
premier ministre a eu parfaitement
raison de dire que la sécurité des biens
et des personnes doit être garanti dans
votre esprit les fauteurs de désordre
c'est l'opposition où ce sont d'autres
groupes en ce qui concerne les étudiants
et pour ce qui s'est passé à paris cette
fois ci il s'agit visiblement de groupes
d'extrême droite
oui ils cherchent à profiter des
circonstances actuelles et d'un certain
malaise étudiants pour créer le désordre
et la violence
cela est inadmissible et je le condamne
avec célérité
alors moi j'habite justement dans le
quartier dans lequel tout ça se passe
donc je le vois à peu près tous les
soirs en ce moment on voit bien qu'à
quelques centaines de garçons d'une
vingtaine d'années dont une partie sont
des étudiants effectivement d'extrême
droite à sens très bien
puis dans d'autres sont assez autonome
où ces marginaux qui s'agglutinent
toujours quand ya ce genre de choses
pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut pas arriver à
mieux contrôler les choses venir une
fois que les étudiants les vrais qui
défilent de en fonction de leurs propres
objectifs s'en vont ils se dispersent
effectivement pineau reste quelques
centaines - 2000 pourquoi est-ce qu'on
peut pas régler ça mieux si vous
connaissez la solution fait là moi
connaître mais non mais je dire vous
pouvez avoir des idées
d'ailleurs il y a effectivement comme
vous avez pu l'observer vous même un
certain nombre d'agitateurs d'extrême
droite qui crée le désordre avec la
grande masse des étudiants et j'ai pu
l'observer en ce qui concerne les
étudiants en médecine on peut
parfaitement engager le dialogue et
trouver des solutions
pendant dix heures j'ai reçu les
représentants des étudiants en médecine
j'essayais de les comprendre et beaucoup
de leurs revendications me paraissait
justifié ces étudiants s'interroge au
fond sur leur avenir
et lorsque l'on parle avec eux de cette
manière là on trouve généralement la
solution alors au fond il ya deux thèmes
dans le projet de loi de réforme
l'enseignement supérieur qui inquiètent
visiblement les étudiants et qui ne leur
paraissent pas très clair l'or sont des
sujets généraux je vous le demande parce
que vous êtes membre du gouvernement à
un niveau important dont vous avez
sûrement des idées là-dessus c'est la
sélection est ce que l à dire
l'enseignement supérieur il faut une
sélection et si oui à quel moment ça
doit être à l'entrée ou est-ce que ça
doit être à la fin de ce qu'on appelle
le premier site d enseignement supérieur
dix ans après deux ans d'études et puis
l'autre question c'est est ce qu'on doit
introduire dans la formation supérieure
davantage de professionnalisation
en ce qui concerne la sélection
devant il faut entrer dans
l'enseignement supérieur ensuite il faut
passer d'une année sur l'autre
les dispositions qui sont dans la loi
qui va être discuté par le parlement
concerne ce qu'on appelle dans un terme
un peu compliqué l'interdisciplinarité
se dire on va pratiquer diverses
disciplines de manière à pouvoir
éventuellement choisir une filière
différentes
il ya là non pas une sélection mais un
examen qui permet de rentrer ensuite
dans le deuxième cycle et pour le reste
il y à un contrôle et un examen de fin
de deuxième cycle me paraît tout à fait
normaux et je souhaite en effet que
l'université comme l'école d'une manière
générale s'ouvre vers la vie active et
notamment vers l'industrie
c'est en créant une symbiose entre
l'enseignement supérieur et la vie
professionnelle que l' on adaptera le
mieux possible les étudiants à leur
tâche d'avenir alors avant d'en arriver
aux problèmes politiques je vous pose
une dernière question sur ce sujet parce
que je crois que c'est un sujet du jour
et que ça intéresse beaucoup de gens un
des problèmes qui visiblement préoccupe
les étudiants et leurs parents
d'ailleurs c'est de savoir s'ils
continueront comme ç'avait été une des
novations oui ou non à pouvoir choisir
l'université de leur choix ou bien s'ils
ne risquent pas d'être affectés en
fonction de critères géographiques un
peu mécanique
non il n'y aura pas de critères
mécanique mais il ya effectivement des
affectations en fonction des choix qui
seront faits par les étudiants bon alors
maintenant j'en arrive aux questions
politiques
françois henri de virieu le disais dans
sa présentation c'est vrai qu' on est
deux ans après le 10 mai en gros un deux
jours près alors il ya une question à
laquelle je crois qu'on ne peut pas
échapper quand le président mitterrand
est élu il avait fait une première
déclaration que j'ai relu et dans cette
déclaration il expliqué qu'au fond le
dit mais ça n'était pas tellement la
victoire de l'un ou de l'autre d'un camp
ou d'un autre c'était la victoire de
l'espoir
c'était et terme deux ans après quand on
regarde les sondages d'opinion plus
quand on écoute les gens on voit bien
qu'au fond les adversaires de la
majorité sont déjà mobilisés et puis je
dirais presque
presque car nous en tout cas combatif et
que les partisans de la majorité sont
désenchantés
comment est-ce que vous pierre bérégovoy
vous expliquer cette évolution sa
rapidité
écoutez nous sommes dans une crise
économique qui est mondial nous avons
pris le pouvoir dans le cas de cette
crise que les socialistes avaient
analysé depuis longtemps nous avions dit
qu'elle était profonde et qu'elle serait
durable et nous l'avons dit en 1971
nous avons pas attendu 1983 pour la
découvrir ce que françois mitterrand
avait dit au cours de sa campagne
électorale
c'est qu'il fallait est en effet ouvrir
une perspective à la france sur le plan
international et sur le plan national
si nous devions faire un bilan
aujourd'hui nous constaterions que sur
le plan international la voix de la
france est entendue et qu'elle est
respectée en ce qui concerne le plan
national les difficultés de leur trouble
l'opinion publique trouve les français
et je ne le conteste pas seulement il
faut savoir que ce que nous avons
accompli depuis deux ans est en passe de
réussir
il suffit maintenant en de rassembler
les énergies
d'abord sur le plan social dans été moi
de le dire puisqu'il s'agit d'un domaine
que je connais bien les mesures que nous
avons prises droit à la retraite à 60
ans lois auroux sur le droit
d'expression des travailleurs les la
cinquième semaine de congés payés
m la réduction de la durée du travail
tout cela est accepté et les français
n'accepteraient pas que cela soit remis
en cause
ils ont ri ils le disent même dans
l'hypothèse où monsieur chirac
monsieur giscard monsieur bart qui se
partagent leur espoir pour demain
revenait au pouvoir
donc il y à un acquis social reconnu par
tout le monde mais pourtant ils sont pas
contents rue ministre siècle est ce
qu'être la retraite à 60 ans on évacue
par les difficultés faire les
générations qui vont nous suivre
je ne le crois absolument pas ce qu'on
ne crée pas
alors les générations puisque puisque
justement on parle de rétrocession on
est on est très convaincant rentabilisé
car est très convergente
c'est très clair gens à vivre vraiment
derrière inquiétés de l'instance il ya
une question que justement qui est
directement liée à sa question en
général mais que beaucoup de gens se
pose puisque beaucoup de gens nous ont
envoyé des lettres à ce sujet avant
cette émission quand ils ont su vous
sera l'invité et cette question c'est
celle ci au fond il ya de moins en moins
de gens qui travaillent de moins en
moins longtemps puisque d'abord il ya
des chômeurs malheureusement qu'ensuite
la retraitée plus vient plus vite
et puis qu'on travaille moins dans la
semaine et puis il ya donc de plus en
plus de retraités qui heureusement
vivent de plus en plus tard grâce à la
médecine qui sont de plus en plus
nombreux comment est-ce que non pas deux
ans mais à 20 ans les premiers pourront
faire vivre les secondes sans qu'il soit
une augmentation massive de ce qu'on
doit payer des cotisations soit à une
limitation des prestations je ferais si
vous ouvrez bien
trois observations la première la
retraite à 60 ans est un droit et ce
n'est pas une obligation
et c'est ainsi qu'il faut voir le
problème ceux qui désirent partir à 60
ans pourront le faire
le deuxième c'est lorsque nous avons
adopté cette disposition est ensuite
trouvé avec les partenaires sociaux le
chemin de l'accord et croyez moi ce
n'était pas facile
nous avons constaté qu'à l'horizon de
2005 le rapport entre les actifs et les
inactifs resterait le même
qu'aujourd'hui après 2005
le problème peut se poser mais peut se
poser pourquoi parce que ce sont
aujourd'hui les actifs qui financent par
des cotisations sociales la retraite des
inactifs
or il y a d'autre moyen de financer
l'inquiète
on peut par exemple aurait abandonné la
répartition le mode actuel et quels
moyens de financement pour l'instant ce
sont des cotisations sociales mais on
peut envisager l'hypothèse à partir de
ce n'est pas tout à fait pour demain où
les machines prendraient leur part au
financement des retraites et de la
protection sociale talibans mettez moi
d'ajouter un dernier mot
c'est que j'ai toujours entendu c'est la
3ème observation
j'ai toujours entendu dire que les
réformes sociales ça coûtait cher
c'était impossible
on ne connaîtrait pas le développement
quand les travailleurs n'avaient pas le
repos dominical
on lisait déjà dans une certaine presse
que cela mettrait l'économie a mal pour
les plus anciens qui ont connu 1936 on
se rappelle aussi que c'était le même
genre d'argumentation les quinze jours
de congés payés c'était impossible
vous voyez où nous en sommes c'est
organisera c'est vrai par conséquent je
crois qu'il faut aborder les choses avec
une conviction qui est la mienne c'est
que le progrès technique il va continuer
à se développer là et qu'il créera des
richesses qui permettront de satisfaire
les besoins des jeunes et les besoins
des anciens je n'en doute pas c'est ce
que vous vouliez dire en disant à
l'instant que les machines prendraient
leur part dans le financement ce que
2005 2005 2005 c'est simple 2005 en gros
c'est dans vingt ans dans 20 ans c'est à
dire que ceux qui commencent à
travailler aujourd'hui mettons à 25 ans
bah ça sera la responsabilité quand ils
seront dans la force de l'âge monsieur
duhamel les richesses sont produites
comment elles sont produites par des
hommes elles sont produites aussi par
des machines
les hommes y met la force de leur esprit
leur intelligence ils mettent aussi la
force de leurs bras et les machines ont
pris depuis des années une part de plus
en plus importante
je veux dire par là qu'il y aura dans
les années 2000 et peut être même avant
davantage de robots qui se substitueront
à l'homme il y aura par conséquent un
effet du progrès technique qui permettra
de produire davantage de richesse avec
sans doute moins d'hommes et de femmes
au travail
voilà ce que je veux dire par conséquent
il faudra trouver d'autres formes de
cotisation cause réelle assise sur les
salaires oui pour financer c'est ça et
les retraites et la protection sociale
en ce sens en préparation sans freiner
la même région cela freinerait d'autant
moins que je croie que la modernisation
nous permettra de financer les ménages
comme ce ne sont ni les robots ni
l'ordinateur qui paieront leur
quote-part ça veut donc dire que skins
us reviendra pas de cotisations assises
sur les salaires et sur les revenus ça
viendra d'autres choses ça viendra de
cotisation corrompus au fisc par exemple
ou bien bien entendu mais vous vous
posez le problème dans le terme de
cotisation naturellement puisque
actuellement il s'agit de cotisation des
gens sont assez sensibles moi je vous
pose deux problèmes de venir un peu
différente et que les françaises et les
français qui m'écoutent vont comprendre
il y a des richesses qui sont produites
et sont produites par des machines par
des hommes et il faut j'ajoute quelque
chose
des capitaux aussi dans une entreprise
pour la faire marcher ensuite on se
partage ses richesses une partie est
consommé une partie est investie et bien
il y aura là dans la partie qui est
consommé ce qui est fait dès aujourd'hui
pour la jeunesse et ce qui sera fait
naturellement pour les personnes âgées
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire en
termes très simples bons alors
jean-pierre chevènement votre ami jean
pierre chevènement qui était ministre
d'état dans le gouvernement auquel vous
appartenez toujours et qu'il ne l'est
plus depuis quelques semaines
apparemment de son fait vient de publier
deux articles dans le monde qui ont fait
beaucoup de bruit
alors quand je voudrais en prendre trois
points que je prendrais successivement
le premier est dit d'abord et là je
voudrais savoir si vous êtes d'accord ou
pas d'accord avec lui il dit d'abord il
faut être clair les grosses difficultés
ne sont pas derrière nous elles sont
devant nous c'est ce que faisait le bon
roi disait la même chose dans ce studio
il ya deux mois ce que vous êtes
d'accord
est-ce que les difficultés sont devant
nous les difficultés nous les vivons
tous les jours et ces difficultés il y
en a qui sont derrière nous je pense par
exemple que nous avons fait des progrès
en ce qui concerne la lutte contre
l'inflation
il faut d'ailleurs maintenir cet effort
car il ne faut pas que l'inflation
dépasse 8 % cette année nous avons
maintenu de chômage dans des limites
raisonnables et il ya une grosse
difficulté que nous vivons aujourd'hui
qui est encore devant nous c'est le
déficit du commerce extérieur viendrait
si jean pierre chevènement veut dire
cela il a raison de considérer que nous
n'avons pas réduit le déficit du
commerce extérieur et qu'il faut nous y
attaquer je le développe près cette idée
quand vous me poserez la question
alors il m'a dit à tripoli dit il et en
barrois ou de jean pierre chevènement
vous venez de dire monsieur de vireux
qu'il avait dit la même chose vous dire
qu'ils avaient des rencontres et foutez
vous leur poserait la question à l'un et
à l'autre
j'ai fait la synthèse en disant qu'il y
avait des difficultés qui était derrière
nous et qu'il en avait encore quelques
unes qui étaient devant nous et auxquels
il faut s'attaquer très courageux alors
jean pierre chevènement il a dit une
seconde chose qui a frappé c'est que la
gauche dans son ensemble n'était pas
parvenu à dissiper le sentiment de la
précarité c'est son mot du pouvoir vous
vous sentez précaire
quelle est la durée devant tel par les
institutions cependant ma nature de me
sentir en situation précaire jeu c'est
plutôt tendance à considérer que nous
avons la durée pour nous le président de
république a été élu pour sept ans et
encore cinq ans devant lui et il fera
croyez moi beaucoup de choses dans ces
cinq ans je connaisse volonté je connais
sa persévérance et je sais aussi comment
il sait maîtriser le temps quand l
assemblée nationale
on vient encore trois ans dans ces trois
ans nous allons redresser l'économie
j'en ai la conviction oui ou ce que je
reproche un peu au papier que l'on voit
ici ou là s'aiment bien si lui une sorte
de doute
or moi je ne doute pas dans la capacité
de notre pays je ne doute pas dans la
capacité des français à surmonter la
crise actuelle
encore faut-il qu'ils aient conscience
des difficultés et le problème du
commerce extérieur c'est une vraie
difficulté
en effet vous le savez comme moi l'année
dernière nous avons fait 93 milliards de
déficit du commerce extérieur c'est un
déficit important
bon alors ce qui signifie quoi si vous
le permettez un que l'on ne vend pas
assez à l'étranger et qu'on achète trop
alors le bon sens nous dit il faut
vendre davantage et il faut acheter un
peu moins vendre davantage quand les
pluies mondiale est en crise ce n'est
pas très facile
acheter un peu moins c'est ce que je
recommanderai aux français sans
protectionnisme sans cordon sanitaire
voulez-vous que je vous donne un exemple
l'année dernière
un français sur trois a acheté une
voiture étrangère
je répète que c'est le droit des
français d'acheter une voiture étrangère
mais si la moitié des français qui ont
acheté une voiture étrangère avait
acheté une voiture française on aurait
fait 25 milliards d'économies en ce qui
concerne la balance de notre commerce
extérieur
moi je dis aux françaises et aux
français ça vaut le coup tout de même
d'agir dans cette direction bon ben on
assure sa loi sur sur trois ou moins sur
ce point sur ce point précis du commerce
extérieur
la france à un déficit important elle
vient à nouveau de souscrire un emprunt
important puisque c'est l'équivalent en
gros 2 4 milliards de dollars
elle continue à avoir des prix qui
augmentent en gros encore trois fois
plus vite que ceux de ses principaux
concurrents
est-ce qu'il ya moyen de réduire
effectivement comme c'est votre objectif
le déficit du commerce extérieur en
évitant avant la fin de l'année soit une
quatrième d'évaluation soit et on dit
que vous y êtes favorable la sortie du
système monétaire européen qui en fait
qui en fait comment sera naturellement
par une dévaluation de fait je dis ça
parce que tout le monde n'est pas
technicien ordi tant de choses qui ne
faut pas croire tout ce que l'on dit
c'est vrai que je n'ai pas la religion
du système monétaire européen
et permettez moi de vous dire que cette
question est derrière nous le
gouvernement a choisi de rester dans le
système monétaire européen et je suis
totalement solidaire du gouvernement
donc pour vous restez majestueux pas
question par exemple dans ma question
était plus précise que ça c'était
jusqu'à la fin de l'année autrement dit
dans votre esprit au 31 décembre de
cette année la france appartiendra
toujours au système monétaire européen
mais je le souhaite je dirais même que
je ferai tout pour qu'il en soit ainsi
car si aucun problème se pose en matière
de d'ajustement monétaire
cela voudra dire que nous aurons réussi
et vous avez posé une vraie question
il ne faut pas que la france voit un
écart trop important entre ses prix et
ceux de ses voisins
c'est pourquoi le gouvernement a proposé
aux français de gagner ensemble la
bataille de l'inflation en faisant en
sorte que les prix n'augmentent pas de
plus de 8% cette année je dis bien lui
pour cent et pas plus de 5% l'année
prochaine
cela signifie naturellement une volonté
collective
cela suit cela signifie un effort de
discipline en matière d'évolution des
prix et en matière d'évolution des
revenus c'est pourquoi nous demandons
aux françaises et aux français de
prendre conscience de l'enjeu
car si nos prix continuer à augmenter
d'une manière
importante que se passerait-il nous
serions en situation difficile sur le
plan de la compétition internationale
nous rencontrerions des difficultés
monétaires et finalement la france
s'endetterait ce qui serait grave et il
ne faut pas qu elle s'endette
aujourd'hui l'endettement est
parfaitement supportable au delà ça
présenterait des risques et nous
risquerions de perdre notre indépendance
économique
c'est pourquoi la bataille d'aujourd'hui
nous avons dit vous savez que nous
sommes dans une sorte de guerre
économique
c'est une bataille qui intéresse toutes
les français
toutes les françaises et tous les
français mais la dernière question je
voulais vous poser la question je
voulais vous poser qui est exactement
dans la ligne de sa vous adresser aux
français comme vous venez de le faire
comment comment est-ce que ils peuvent
être eux mêmes les français normaux
venir les citoyens sincèrement convaincu
à partir du moment où vos propres amis
dont dans la politique et le métier qui
sont ceux de votre parti alors le leader
officiel du parti dit qu'il faut pas se
sentir persécuté par un complexe d'échec
le président du groupe à l'assemblée et
le président la commission des finances
disent que cette politique économique
elle est quand même bien critiquable
monsieur poperen dit qu'à l'affrontement
des classes afin je veux dire ya une
cacophonie de vos propres amis sur lui à
mails je n'exagère pas le parti
socialiste rassemble des femmes et des
hommes deux tempéraments différents des
sensibilités comme l'on dit diverses et
je trouve naturel que les socialistes
discute mais ça vous gêne pas là en ce
moment je n'ai pas à me mêler en tant
que membre du gouvernement de ces
discussions est ce qu'il serait pas sain
c'est que les ministres s'en mêle et
petit avoir en effet au gouvernement
qu'une seule ligne politique celle ci a
été fixé par le président de la
république est aujourd'hui développés
sous l'autorité du premier ministre vous
j'aime parler en ce qui concerne les
socialistes permettez moi d'ajouter
quelque chose c'est que la discussion
chez les socialistes a fait la richesse
de notre parti et si j'ai un conseil
aujourd'hui à donner à mes camarades
socialistes c'est qu'ils discutent mais
qu'ils sachent à nouveau se rassembler
lors du prochain congrès et je suis
convaincu qu
lionel jospin aujourd'hui comme françois
mitterrand hier sera fédérer les
socialistes deuxième conseil si vous le
permettez puisque celle occasion de dire
mon attachement au parti socialiste
je crois que le parti socialiste peut
nous aider aujourd'hui à découvrir
l'avenir nous connaissons une crise
économique dont j'ai déjà parlé il ya
aussi une crise culturelle
il y as entre rap dérape les rapports
nouveau entre l'homme et l'état entre
l'homme et l'entreprise
il y a notamment tenu à donner toute
leur place aux femmes dans notre société
nous avons sur ce terrain là beaucoup de
choses à faire encore ensemble et je
souhaiterais que les socialistes
eh bien nous aident à découvrir
l'horizon 1990 et moins alors ils ont
quelques idées à la du hamel de relancer
par la discussion on est déjà passé de 7
minutes philippe vasseur et alors on va
voir si vous avez été compris par les
français
svp ce qui a des réactions oui des
questions nommément réaction je dois
dire que nous avons énormément de
questions et que nous avons énormément
de questions qui portent sur deux thèmes
visiblement les gens n'ont rien compris
au problème des pré retraites mais vous
pose énormément de questions là dessus
et les gens vous pose énormément de
questions sur le forfait hospitalier est
peut-être puis je vous posais cette
question qui résume toutes les autres
quelles conditions faut-il remplir pour
ne pas payer le forfait hospitalier de
20 francs vous aimez les eaux est fondée
je voudrais d'abord faire une remarque
je suis profondément attaché à la
sécurité sociale et j'ai observé que 85%
des français considèrent qu'il s'agit
d'une grande conquête sociale et je suis
obligé de d'assurer l'équilibré des
comptes de la sécurité sociale car si
nous laissions se creuser un déficit
dans les comptes de la sécurité sociale
c'est l'institution elle même qui se
trouverait compromise or il y à des
dépenses et il y a des recettes
j'ai refusé l'an passé d'augmenter les
cotisations sociales à la charge des
entreprises et à la charge des salariés
pour financer la sécurité sociale
il m'a donc fallu rechercher un certain
nombre d'économies dans la gestion de
grandes réformes sont en cours
je pense notamment à la maîtrise de la
dépense spital hier et puis comme nous
sommes de ceux qui pensions que la
médecine est actuellement en train de
connaître une évolution à tournant et
que les soins à domicile sont
aujourd'hui possibles et les soins à
domicile sont possibles pour des
maladies importantes je pense par
exemple aux dialyse rénale
on peut soigner à domicile un cancer
grave par la chimiothérapie et bien nous
avons voulu établir une sorte d'égalité
entre eux le malade qui est hospitalisée
pour shu et le malade qui a choisi de se
faire soigner à domicile c'est fred diaz
et offrait il y a beaucoup d'exemption
notamment pour la maternité pour les
accidentés du travail pour les personnes
handicapées pour les anciens combattants
toutes ces catégories sont exemptés du
forfait journalier et celles et ceux qui
ne peuvent pas payer le forfait
journalier ont parfaitement la
possibilité de s'adresser à l'aide
sociale
nous avons demandé 20 fera par jour ce
qui n'est pas considérable à celles et à
ceux qui le peuvent
et je le répète avec l'idée d'établir
une justice entre ce que l'on soigne à
domicile et ceux qui sont soignés à
l'hôpital philippe harrouard il y
intervenir oui les gens visiblement nous
pose beaucoup de questions à propos des
handicapés physiques et nous demandent
pourquoi le forfait hospitalier
s'applique-t-il aux enfants handicapés
physiques et puis on nous dit aussi
est-ce que les 20 francs de
contributions hospitalières sont
justifiées pour tout le monde sans tenir
compte des salaires les 20 francs sont
justifiées pour toutes les catégories
dont j'ai parlé avant traitement sont
utiles pour toutes celles qui ne sont
pas dans les catégories dont j'ai parlé
bien pour le reste
j'observe que par exemple les personnes
âgées les personnes qui sont démunis de
ressources ne paieront pas ces 20 francs
l'aide sociale est là pour isuppli
en ce qui concerne les enfants des
handicapés ils ne doivent pas payer les
20 francs alors on me dit qu'il peut y
avoir des cas dans des centres de
rééducation où le problème se poserait
je donnerai des instructions pour que le
problème ne se pose plus d'accord donc
vous le signalera ces cas philippe
vasseur et monsieur bérigaud grèce
viennent vous entendre en répondant à
une question des téléspectateurs dire
que vous attacher beaucoup d'importance
l équilibre de la sécurité sociale c'est
très bien c'est apprécié qui me paraît
très très sain il n'ya pas qu'en matière
de sécurité sociale que vous avez des
problèmes d'argent il ya aussi les
déficits dans l'assurance chômage est le
problème des retraites on en a parlé
tout à l'heure
alors comment allez vous faire pour
régler tous ces problèmes pour essayer
de parvenir à l'équilibré de solution ou
vous tailler dans les dépenses et à dire
que vous diminuer les prestations vous
augmenter les recettes sont là comment
par les cotisations
on a déjà donné par l'impôt sur le
revenu on a déjà donné ou plutôt on va
encore donner ou alors par une autre par
un autre moyen par exemple une
augmentation de la tva je sais que vous
y pense un peu ramener les choses à leur
proportion si vous le voulez bien et je
vais d'abord parlé de la sécurité
sociale c'est vrai que nous avons eu un
déficit de 6 milliards de francs en 1981
un déficit du même ordre en 1982 et
qu'en 1983 de l'ordre de 4 à 5 milliards
selon les prévisions
je vous fais remarquer que le budget de
la sécurité sociale est de l'ordre de
550 milliards
il y à la branche maladie la branche
famille et la branche vieillesse
ça veut dire que notre déficit est un
déficit annuel ne dépasse pas 1%
non mais je parle des déficits cumulés
c'est à dire de ceux de toutes les
informations à le fait tout de même
remarquer que 1 % ce n'est pas
considérable mais il est en effet
inacceptable de considérer que le
déficit pourrait perdurer
d'année en année alors je le dis et je
vais le répéter il n'y a pas 36
solutions
ou bien on augmente les recettes donc
les cotisations ou bien on essaie de
maîtriser les dépenses et c'est ce que
nous essayons de faire et permettez moi
de vous dire que nous avons réalisé des
économies importantes
ne serait-ce qu'en faisant prendre
conscience aux français de l'importance
des enjeux
j'ai constaté par exemple que du 1er
avril 1982 au 31 mars 1983
les dépenses de l'assurance maladie sont
en déclin d'une manière intéressante et
sur les trois premiers mois de l'année
nous atteindrons nos objectifs
il faut que chacun prenne conscience
qu'il est responsable de la dépense les
professions médicales doivent en prendre
conscience et les assurés aussi les
gestionnaires des hôpitaux naturellement
également alors il y à des églises vous
excluez pratiquement toute augmentation
de construire les économies que l'on
peut faire et dans l'est d'autre que
l'on ne peut pas faire je ne réaliserai
pas d'économie qui met en péril la
protection sociale et le droit à la
santé des français parce que considère
que ce droit doit être garantie c'est
vrai qu'il y à des investissements à
faire il ya des problèmes qui se posent
et il faut les assumer
alors quelles sont les recettes
possibles eh bien vous remarquerez que
l'an dernier j'ai fait appel à une
cotisation sur le tabac et sur l'alcool
voilà une première disposition une forme
de fiscalisation
pourquoi parce qu'on y voit je parle des
recettes futures dans quelle recette
actuelle on les connaît bien on les
connaît bien mais je voudrais tout de
même les expliquer simplement pour vous
faire connaître et faire connaître aussi
aux françaises et aux français
la démarche qui est la mienne j'observe
par exemple que l'abus du tabac la
consommation immodérée du tabac de
l'alcool coûte par an à la sécurité
sociale de 25 à 30 milliards de francs à
la collectivité tout entière
on a estimé cela à plus de 100 milliards
de francs est donc posé le problème
osseux n'a pas été acceptée avec plaisir
par tout le monde mais il faut bien que
chacun prenne conscience dans le domaine
de la protection sociale et de la santé
qui lie à un effort à faire
alors vous dites le financement et bien
cette année nous avons effectivement une
recette
assise sur le revenu
un pour cent à la place d'une
augmentation de la cotisation sociale
pourquoi ce 1% sur le revenu de
préférence à la cotisation sociale parce
que la cotisation sociale est payée par
les seuls salariés ou pas ce qu'ils
touchent un revenu professionnel et nous
considérons que c'est injuste alors
qu'une
c'est ce 1% ainsi sur l'ensemble des
revenus professionnels et du capital est
plus juste il ya donc des moments où
l'on peut faire appel à la fiscalité
doite
on fait appel à la tva doit-on faire
appel à une autre solution qui
consisterait à modifier l'assiette et à
faire intervenir dans l'assiette je
m'excuse c'est un peu technique d'une
part les salaires et d'autre part la
valeur ajoutée de l'entreprise
nous réfléchissons à des sources de
financement qui fasse qui corrige ce
qu'actuellement d'injuste la cotisation
sociale assise exclusivement sur le
salaire c'est pas de solution vraiment
nouvelle jeu ça fait des années qu'on
entend réfléchir à ce type de solutions
oui mais j'ai la volonté de les faire
aboutir monsieur de virieu et je
voudrais ajouter d'ailleurs que s'il y
avait eu une cotisations sociales
assises sur les salaires
tous les salariés y compris ceux qui
sont payés au smic qui gagne 3504
lisfranc l'aurait payé alors qu'avec l'
un plat pour cent sont exonérés tous
ceux qui ne paient pas d'impôts donc par
conséquent les personnes qui sont payés
au smic que nous avons tenu compte aussi
des charges fallu n'ya rien tout le
monde l'appelle les charges familiales
je reste sur le 1% si vous voulez bien
ce qui veut dire qu'il y a un foyer sur
trois un foyer fiscal sur trois qui ne
paiera pas le 1% sur le revenu autrement
dit chaque fois que nous avons
aujourd'hui à choisir une mesure n'est
ce pas nous essayons de l'afld de faire
en sorte qu'elle soit juste et qu'elle
soit équitable
j'ai déjà dit monsieur vasseur qu'on ne
peut pas distribuer plus que ce que l'on
a
je suis partisan d'une bonne gestion et
je le répète et je demande aux
françaises et aux français aux assurés
sociaux de mai d assurer une bonne
gestion mais on peut mieux répartir ce
que l'on a
et chaque fois que j'ai une décision a
proposé au gouvernement et au premier
ministre monsieur pierre mauroy
je propose une décision inspirée du
principe suivant demander moins à celui
qui n'a pas beaucoup même mieux apporter
un peu plus à celui qui n'a pas beaucoup
et demander un peu plus à celui qui se
trouve au haut de l'échelle des revenus
et des patrimoines
c'est ainsi que la solidarité
aujourd'hui doit être pratiquée ce que
voit il ya deux ans vous êtes au pouvoir
en deux ans il ya eu près de quatre cent
mille chômeurs de plus mais je reconnais
c'est vrai que le
s'est stabilisée grâce à ce que monsieur
mon roi appelle un traitement social du
chômage
j'ai l'impression que les mesures qui
ont été prises ne pourront pas être
renouvelés éternellement par exemple on
sait que le plan de rigueur risquent
d'aggraver le chômage chez monsieur de
l'or qu'il dit on sait aussi que le
secteur public maintenant on ne peut
plus embaucher il débauche même on
supprime des emplois dans le secteur
public à la sncf chez péchiney chez
saint gobain pour prendre les derniers
exemples ne débouche pas qu'ils
suppriment des emplois pardon ils
suppriment des emplois on en serait un
peu moins sûr présente loi 15 100
emplois en moins à la sncf c'est pas moi
qui le dit c'est nocif il termine donc
là dessus je tiens mes sources
êtes vous d'accord avec moi pour dire
qu'on ne débouche g10 supprimer des
emplois trajet rectifier alors on
supprime des emplois dans le secteur
public
combien de chômeurs y aura-t-il à la fin
de l'année c'est une question importante
et qui soucie le ministre des affaires
sociales
soyez en certains en effet pour assurer
l'équilibré du commerce extérieur il
nous faut réduire les importations
j'ai dit tout à l'heure que l'on pouvait
faire appel au génie des français alors
aide pour essayer de régler ce problème
mais comme nous avons décidé de réduire
la demande qui aura un effet donc
mécanique sur les importations
ça peut avoir aussi un effet sur la
production et comme l'a dit mon collègue
jacques delors se peut augmenter
d'environ 60 mille 80000 personnes le
nombre des chômeurs et c'est ici qu'il
faut faire preuve d'imagination
en effet lorsque nous parlons des
problèmes de l'emploi du travail
nous raisonnons toujours en termes de
macroéconomie employons un mot plus
simple de grands équilibres économiques
et financiers
de quoi qu'il faut raisonner disons à la
base sur le terrain dans les régions par
exemple on peut sans doute prendre des
initiatives et créer des emplois
autre exemple sur lequel on pourrait
faire un effort
les économies d'énergie le gouvernement
a décidé l'an passé
un crédit de 2 milliards de francs pour
les économies d'énergie
ce crédit de 2 milliards de francs a
entraîné six milliards de travaux cela
veut dire par conséquent que ces 6
milliards de travaux
hormis de mieux isoler les appartements
de d'installer des appareils de faire
des économies d'énergie ce qui est
intéressant dans notre balance
commerciale
et ça a créé on sait que des mesures
comme cela et d'eau et laissez vous à
dire de résultat positif c'est que ça a
créé 60 milles à 70 mille emplois il
m'est arrivé de parler de croissance
sociale la croissance sociale qu'est ce
que cela veut dire
cela veut dire qu'il nous faut relancer
l'activité naturellement et en tenant
compte des contraintes internationales
ce qui n'est pas très facile mais en
essayant d'avoir une activité en france
qu'ils fassent - appel - appel aux
importations
alors voilà l'exemple économies
d'énergie on a économisé je crois
pouvant vous dire 1 % de l'énergie
importée
grâce à ses 2 milliards on peut faire
encore plus non mais de combien de
chômeurs à la fin de l'année mais c'est
leur ego
je vous ai dit qu'on pouvait craindre qu
qui préoccupe tous les je le comprends
bien je vous dit qu'elle me préoccupe
aussi je vous ai dit il ya un risque
mécanique de 60000 à 80 mille chômeurs
de plus répète ce qu'a dit mon ami
jacques delors et vous savez il est
comme moi et ils regardent les effets
mécaniques du plan et puis ils essaient
de trouver comme moi des solutions je
vous envie de les unes mais il y en a
beaucoup d'autres
par exemple la réalisation de la
réduction du temps de travail vous avez
fait un bilan de la réduction du temps
de travail est ce que vous savez combien
l'emploi s'est permis de créer combien
salaires réduction du temps de travail a
permis de créer
vous parlez des 39 heures oui les 39
heures et prennent la cinquième
destination sous les sons variable entre
50 milles et 70 mille emplois mais c'est
5 août mais combien aux entreprises et
aboutit aussi haut de leur 2 les 39
heures qui ne se répercute pas de
l'ordre de 8 milliards je crois mais
c'est de ce sont des chiffres ou les qui
mérite vérification ça fait cher en
étant même nom mais parce que vous ne
voyez que les emplois créés
permettez moi de vous dire aussi le
nombre d'emplois que cela éviter de
supprimer car c'est cela une question
très importante et vous allez loin comme
la cfdt le demande vous allez encore
diminuer la durée de travail
nous n'allons pas diminuer la durée du
travail par la voie légale
nous entendons en effet nous tenir à la
semaine de 39 heures
or telle qu'elle est inscrite
aujourd'hui dans la loi par contre nous
allons encourager et je crois au
dialogue social les entreprises et les
syndicats à discuter et à voir sur le
terrain ce que l'on peut faire
nous avons déjà nous un contrat de
solidarité réductions de travail qui
peut être utilisé mais nous avons aussi
d'autres possibilités
c'est aujourd'hui quel est le problème
pour la réduction de la durée du temps
de travail
ces cas les salariés qui se disent nous
on voudrait bien travaillé une heure de
moins mais on ne voudrait pas gagner
moins pour ce qu'ils sont c'est un 4000
à 5000 francs de revenus mensuels je les
comprends parfaitement
alors les entreprises d'y jouer mais on
ne peut pas à lui de réduire le temps de
travail car sinon nous allons alourdir
nos charges disputons voyons ce qui est
possible de faire par exemple peut-on
travailler le samedi
autrement dit je crois qu'une des
solutions pour à bourthes y aboutir à la
réduction de la durée du temps de
travail c'est de faire travailler moins
les hommes aient davantage de machines
c'est vrai pour la période que nous
connaissons actuellement et permettez
moi de vous dire que ça sera vrai
surtout dans le futur quand on voit les
progrès de l'informatique des progrès de
la robotique et bien on se dit que le
problème de la réduction du temps de
travail
il est devant nous et qu'il faut
l'absent l'aborder a avec lucidité et il
faut faire confiance à ceux qui sont sur
le terrain
les chefs d'entreprise comme les
syndicats moi je suis partisan du
dialogue social
car je crois à l'efficacité du dialogue
permettez moi de vous dire que lorsqu'il
a fallu régler le problème de la
retraite à 60 ans eh bien j'ai rencontré
des représentants syndicaux ensuite je
les ai réunis et je me suis aperçu que
lorsque l'on discute les 1 face aux
autres on a une volonté d'aboutir
on trouve toujours la bonne solution je
recommande donc aux représentants du
cnpf aux représentants des syndicats de
discuter branche par branche si c'est
possible
entreprise par entreprise c'est le bon
chemin pour aboutir pour aboutir à une
réduction de la durée du travail qui
effectivement maintiennent car j'y tiens
beaucoup
la compétitivité de nos entreprises
alors précisément quand les partenaires
sociaux discutent ils disent que le
gouvernement joue pas le jeu vous avez
vu ce qu'a dit monsieur
tard dans une interview hier avant-hier
au matin il disait par exemple sur la
loi rigaux la fameuse loi sur la
formation professionnelle on s'était mis
d'accord avec les syndicats on avait
signé quelque chose et puis le
gouvernement a décidé d'en rajouter là
on n'est plus d'accord c'est un casus
belli ya plus de négociations possibles
et plus de politique contractuelle mais
c'est un fait précis concrets monsieur
l'auteur a élevé le ton quand il dit il
n'y a plus de politique contractuelle
j'entends aussi dire par d'autres que on
a du mal aujourd'hui à rencontrer les
patrons pour discuter réduction de la
durée du travail ou tel ou tel problème
là vous les voyez la semaine prochaine
oui je parlerai avec eux vous savez avec
intérêt et avec la volonté de trouver
des solutions
que dit la loi à rigaud sur la formation
professionnelle
d'abord le parlement va en être saisi il
ya toujours des possibilités
d'amendement est dit qu on prend en
compte l'accord interprofessionnel de 9
ans en 1982 et on y ajoute simplement
l'obligation de négocier pour adapter la
formation optionnel il d'année en année
un entrepreneur comme il ya un autre
point mais c'est le plus important
il ya celui là il y en a un autre mais
quand les partenaires sociaux se mettent
d'accord pourquoi le gouvernement
ajoute-t-il
est-ce que c'est pas contraire à
l'esprit de la politique contractuelle
parce que la formation professionnelle
c'est une grande affaire la formation
professionnelle la formation permanente
permettez moi de vous dire la formation
tout court c'est une grande affaire et
je crois qu'il est bon que le
gouvernement fixe une orientation
je voudrais à cet égard vous donner un
exemple j'étais à nevers en novembre
dernier et je rencontrais les
responsables d'une entreprise des
aciéries d'imphy et il me faisait part
de leurs difficultés car l'acier il ya
quelques difficultés que vous savez et
il me disait surtout nous sommes
confrontés à une grande interrogation
nous aurons besoin dans les cinq ans qui
viennent de salariés qui seront encore
au niveau du bac et qui auront des
connaissances dans le domaine
informatique car il faudra intégrer les
données de la forme d'informatique dans
pour faire marcher les aciéries de
l'horizon 85 90 je crois un vrai
problème et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai demandé à
savary nous aider à installer des micro
ordinateurs dans les écoles de la nièvre
et j'ai vu avec quel intérêt les jeunes
enfants et les adolescents se saisissait
du micro ordinateur
comment ils on comprenait le langage
comment il était capable finalement de
maîtriser cet instrument ce qui me
serait sans doute à moi un peu plus
difficile sans un apprentissage sans
doute plus lent et bien dire que le
gouvernement ne peut pas être
indifférent ni à la formation des jeunes
ni à la formation professionnelle
car dans le monde où nous sommes la
mobilité professionnelle est devenue
affaire considérable
il y a trente ou quarante ans lorsqu'un
ouvrier ou un employé entrée dans la vie
active
il avait toute chance de faire pendant
les quarante années de sa vie active
le même travail aujourd'hui il va être
obligé de changer deux ou trois fois
d'activité parce que progrès technique
va vite donc par conséquent que le
gouvernement crée les conditions d'une
adaptation permanente de l'homme à son
travail et au travail de l'avenir c'est
ce que signifie la loi sur la formation
professionnelle
ce marigot voix vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure avec alain duhamel des
manifestations qui avaient lieu dans la
rue et de la nécessité de faire
respecter l'ordre républicain ce qui est
tout à fait logique de faire intervenir
les crs avaient quand même une question
qui a été posée par un certain nombre de
gens qui a été mal prise faire
intervenir les crs dans la rue d'accord
quand l'ordre est menacée mais pourquoi
le gouvernement ne fait-il pas respecter
le droit du travail dans un certain
nombre de conflits pourquoi des
décisions de justice ne sont elles pas
appliquer quand il ya des occupations
illégales du sinn
pourquoi des minorités parviennent tel
parfois à empêcher d'autres personnes de
travailler pourquoi y at il deux poids
deux mesures je ne crois pas pourquoi
pourquoi lutter vous contre les
violences dans la rue et pas contre les
violences à l'usiné de bonnes questions
et du batteur soumises
oui mais je le crois pas que l'on puisse
dire cela
monsieur vasseur le gouvernement
respecte le droit de grève et entend
faire respecter le droit au travail
chaque fois qu'il y a eu des occupations
d usines qui interdisait l'exercice du
travail pour ceux qui ne voulaient pas
faire grève le gouvernement a pris des
dispositions qu'il fallait
plusieurs exemples dans la région
parisienne sont là pour en témoigner
de même que nous avons condamné avec
force tous ceux qui étaient
séquestrations de cadres ou de chefs
d'entreprise et la force publique à
jouer elle a joué avec modération il
faut parfois comprendre la colère de
certains salariés
mais l'ordre a été garanti et j'entends
bien puisque j'ai la responsabilité du
travail faire en sorte en effet que les
principes qui fondent l'exercice du
droit de grève et le droit au travail
soient garantis en toutes circonstances
c'est une vision optimiste que les
choses je vous donnerai si vous ne
voulez pas ici mais de nombreux exemples
où dans un certain nombre de cas les
violences n'ont pas été gentil toujours
parler de cela
non mais je donnerai des exemples si
vous le voulez plusieurs régions de
france y compris dans la région
parisienne et notamment dans l'industrie
automobile c'est vrai mon prédécesseur
jean roux s'est exprimé là dessus avec
une très grande fermeté et qu'en ce qui
me concerne il en sera de même
je suis pour le respect intransigeant du
droit de grève et je voudrais bien que
les entreprises les chefs d'entreprises
engagent en temps utile le dialogue avec
les organisations syndicales pour éviter
tous les débordements mais je pense que
le droit au travail doit être respecté
et je me porte garant de son respect une
dernière question monsieur bérégovoy est
ce que la presse va l'enlever la rentrée
sociale sera calme je l'espère c'est de
l'expérience télé y est je l'espère et
si je l'espère je le crois c'est de la
qualité du dialogue social de ce que
nous serons capables de nous et à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise entre les
syndicats et les organisations
patronales en et les chefs d'entreprise
que nous pourrons avoir la chance de
garantir un climat social détendue
j'observe qu'actuellement le climat
social est bon cela veut dire que le
rêve
l'atlas et les années précédant la
classe ouvrière fait preuve d'un esprit
de responsabilité et il y a moins de
jours de grève en ce moment qu'il y en a
eu en 1976-1977 les plus de 80 ans
mais en 1990 80 il peut arriver ici ou
là notamment à cause des tensions sur
l'emploi il y à des grèves
je m'efforce de trouver avec laurent
fabius ni dans l'industrie les chemins
de la concertation mais ce que je veux
surtout vous dire à cet égard c'est que
le dialogue social c'est l'essentiel
dans les circonstances où nous sommes
n'est ce pas lorsque nous avons reconnu
par les lois auroux de nouveaux droits
d'expression aux travailleurs lorsque
nous avons reconnu de nouvelles
responsabilités aux ordinations
syndicale c'est pour faire en sorte que
le travailleur ne soit plus étranger
dans son entreprise
je sais bien que beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprise discutait déjà avec leurs
salariés
d'autres avec un peu trop longtemps
attendu et c'est de ce dialogue de cette
négociation que j'attends beaucoup
vous savez il ne faut pas que le
travailleur sous est étranger aux
conditions de travail cloud quand je
suis entré dans la vie active
on l'a dit tout à l'heure j'étais au
chemin de fer j'accomplissais des tâches
subalternes
mais le travail pour moi c'était un
moyen de libération
c'était un moyen de promotion sociale
aujourd'hui il nous faut parfois
réconcilier le jeune avec le travail
pourquoi parce qu'il ya des tâches
répétitives parce qu'on comprend pas
toujours la signification du travail
parce qu'on se trouve un poste
on ne sait pas ce qui se passe en un mot
on ne sait pas ce qui se passe en aval
et bien appartement où les travailleurs
quand je dis travailleurs cela concerne
ouvriers employés et cadres cas aussi
souvent les cadres ne sont pas beaucoup
plus responsable de leur travail que des
ouvriers employés parce qu'eux aussi
sont un rouage de la machine économique
et bien quand on aura permis à
l'ensemble des travailleurs de dire leur
mot sur les conditions de travail de
participer on aura un climat social
qualité et on aura des entreprises avec
une efficacité économique accrue c'est
en tout cas dans cette direction qu'il
faut aller bon alors albert du roy venir
s'installer pendant ce temps là une
question peut-être vp oui les
téléspectateurs suivent bien il vous a
entendu dire monsieur bérégovoy qu'il
fallait acheter français et ils vous ont
entendu parler des manifestations dans
la rue et les téléspectateurs ont
remarqué que les services de police sont
équipés de voitures étrangères et de
motos étrangères japonaises et
allemandes
alors est ce que le gouvernement ne doit
pas donner l'exemple on nous fait
remarquer aussi que air france achète
des boeing alors que des airbus reste
dans les hangars
donc est ce que le gouvernement ne donne
pas l'exemple on nous demande également
monsieur bérégovoy si vous ressentez
personnellement une baisse du pouvoir
d'achat au niveau de votre salaire
personnel ça c'est une question à
laquelle monsieur mauroy n'avait pas
répondu
la dernière partie les réponses à ces
questions en ce qui concerne les
voitures et les motos elles ont dû être
commandées avant que nous arrivions au
pouvoir mais de toute façon j'en
parlerai à gaston defferre
mais je voudrais dire d'ailleurs à cet
égard qu'il ne s'agit pas n'est ce pas
que la france produisent tout ce dont
elle a besoin et que nous fermions nos
frontières aux produits étrangers il ne
s'agit pas de cela du tout il s'agit
simplement de prendre conscience de
l'enjeu
et comme le président de la république
l'avait dit à qualité égale
chaque fois qu'on le peut préférer un
produit français
autre formule souffler un peu plus
humble je dis avec toute la force de la
conviction
mieux vaut acheter un produit français
que d'avoir un chômeur de plus que ça ça
parle
c'est ainsi qu'il choisit en ce qui
concerne mon traitement il faudrait que
je retrouve cela je pourrais avoir pris
cette note
de là vous dire que le salaire des
ministres a augmenté de 13% depuis le
1er mai 1981
ce qui veut dire qu'il a augmenté à peu
près deux fois moins que la moyenne des
salaires et
les ministres sont assujetties comme les
autres aux cotisations et s'il faut
faire un effort de plus au nom de la
solidarité
je le recommanderais au conseil des
ministres il ya un ministre gagne
combien monsieur le ministre
eh bien écoutez un ministre gagne tout
déduit entre 28000 et 29,8 rend possible
il y as je dois dire d'ailleurs beaucoup
de responsables d'entreprises publiques
et privées qui gagnent beaucoup plus
qu'un ministre c'est pourquoi il faudra
qu'un jour toutes ces choses soient
mises sur la table
quel est à votre avis les vents taille
idéale de salaire dans un pays comme la
france je parle salaire bien entendu
parler de ce qui est comparable savez
c'est à votre question est intéressante
mais elle est difficile car il faut
tenir compte de la peau alors je sais
que par exemple pour ce qui me concerne
les vingt-huit mille se ramène un peu
moins de vingt mille francs une fois que
j'ai payé l'impôt mensuel en fin de cet
ordre là je ne pourrais pas vous le dire
exactement
donc on ne peut faire de comparaison que
impôts déduits
on avait donc parler d'échelle de
revenus entre 1 et 6 ce 1,5
ce sont des ordres de grandeur qui me
paraissent convenable après impôts la
tonne albert d'euros mais je me avant
d'aborder quelques nouveaux thèmes je
voudrais revenir sur quelques unes des
réponses que vous avez fait est que j'ai
entendu comme tout le monde
d'abord quand on a opposé devant vous
des déclarations optimistes de pierre
mauroy et de l'opération pessimiste de
jean pierre chevènement
vous avez dit je suis l'homme de la
synthèse de savoir si c'est une boutade
ou si c'est une réalité
je préfère la synthèse à l'affrontement
mais sans mettre en cause les principes
auxquels je crois profondément
si il m'arrivait un jour être en
désaccord avec telle décision du
gouvernement
je donnerai ma démission mais je pense
que aussi bien dans le parti socialiste
lorsque j ai exercé des responsabilités
aujourd'hui dans la vie publique
il est bon de rapprocher les points de
vue elle n'est jamais tout à fait sûr
qu'on a complètement raison
quand notre conscience vous le dit
notre conviction profonde il faut aller
jusqu'au bout de son raisonnement mais
il faut être attentif à ce que disent
les autres et le ministre de la
solidarité qui a reçoit vous savez plus
de 1000 lettres par jour qu'ils
rencontrent quotidiennement des
représentants d'organisations syndicales
de représentants de parents handicapés
par exemple qui rend compte les médecins
les étudiants en médecine les internes
je les ai eus beaucoup cherchent parfois
purge souvent plutôt sa vérité au
travers de ce dialogue
et lorsque je peux dégager de différents
points de vue une synthèse
lorsque je peux arriver à un accord en
général je suis satisfait et vous
estimez actuellement être bien placée
pour rassembler les points de vue par
exemple au sein du parti socialiste
entre le premier ministre et la
politique de leur disons et l'ailé
gauche du parti socialiste représenté
par monsieur chevènement sûr je n'ai
absolument pas à rapprocher les points
de vue du premier ministre et ceux du
parti socialiste je vous ai dit qu'il y
avait une ligne politique
gouvernementale fixé par le président de
la république appliquée par le
gouvernement sous l'autorité de pierre
mauroy
j'y souscris sans la moindre réserve en
ce qui concerne le parti se dit je me
suis déjà expliqué le parti socialiste
débat c'est sa richesse
il n'arrivera peut-être d'intervenir de
parler à l'un ou à l'autre mais je n'ai
pas à me mêler de cela n'empêche que moi
j'ai interprété votre réponse le parti
socialiste tout à l'heure quand vous
avez dit que les socialistes vous avez
donnez vos conseils que les socialistes
sachent se rassembler au prochain
congrès moi j'ai compris vous souhaitez
vous militants socialistes ce qu'on
appelle une motion de synthèse que tout
le monde se retrouve sur le même texte
quand vous avez ajouté derrière c'était
votre troisième conseil qu'ils nous
aident à préparer l'an 2000
moi j'ai compris et qui se préoccupe un
peu moins de nous critiquer aujourd'hui
absolument pas absolument j'ai dit que
je souhaitais que lionel jospin qui est
le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste puisse rassembler fédérer
autour de lui les différents courants du
parti socialiste et je suis convaincu
que lionel jospin
réussira en tout cas c'est le voeu que
je forme
quant aux socialistes aujourd'hui il
joue un rôle important
lorsqu'il nous alerte sur tel ou tel
point de la politique gouvernementale
lorsqu'ils nous disent à illies à cet
aspect des choses qu'il faut prendre en
considération lorsque je réfléchis à un
avenir de la sécurité sociale lorsque
j'évoque les problèmes de l'assurance
chômage
j'en discute avec les parlementaires
socialistes
les parlementaires communistes les
parlementaires de la majorité et
également avec des responsables
socialistes
il est bon de les entendre et le parti
socialiste a aussi un rôle de
pédagogique
il a un rôle de rassembleur des
socialistes et des français ils ne ne
renvoie pas le parti socialiste à des
travaux sur l'an 2000 je souhaite qu'ils
aident le gouvernement
dans la bataille que celui ci a engagé
mais je souhaite aussi qu'il anime une
réflexion un peu plus long terme
personnellement je suis très préoccupé
par le modèle de société que nous avons
inventé le dit tout à l'heure je n'ai
pas y revenir je crois en effet que le
progrès technique nous interpelle et
voyez vous ce qui m'intéresse
aujourd'hui c'est les années qui
viennent plus que l'immédiat là il
s'agit pendez les énergies et il faut le
faire naturellement avec beaucoup de
courage mais les années qui viennent
sur le plan mondial comme sur le plan
français sont assez redoutable et il
faut que nous soyons capables d'imaginer
de nouveaux rapports sociaux
ça ça concerne notre pays d'imaginer de
nouveaux rapports internationaux par
exemple la situation des pays en voie de
développement nous interpelle et le
développement de la crise monétaire est
aujourd'hui en train de compromettre
l'avenir de ces pays
des milliards d'hommes risque d'être en
difficulté croissante
si nous ne mettons pas un peu d'ordre
dans le système monétaire mondial
voilà une question décisive pour
l'avenir d'humanité avant je fais une
petite parenthèse
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la phrase
de jean poperen de ce qu'il a écrit dans
le dernier numéro de son journal
synthèse flash qui s'inscrit bien
évidemment de la préparation de ce
congrès dont nous avons parlé tout à
l'heure et qui aura lieu en octobre
seulement d'ailleurs on dit toujours à
la veille du congrès c'est en octobre
la phase ii poperen la suivante le fil
conducteur de la politique aujourd'hui
comme hier c'est l'affrontement des
classes et il précise que le ps s'il
veut rester au pouvoir doit
effectivement faire la politique
correspond aux intérêts des gens qui
votent pour lui que pensez vous de cette
analyse là les gens ce que vous faites
est ce que vous êtes au pouvoir pour
faire la politique du front de classe
afin de la partie centrale du front de
classe il vous ellie ou une politique
correspondant à un intérêt général qui
tentait que ce mot existe à notre époque
je vous répondrais sur ce point précis
il faut que l'intérêt général l'emporté
toujours sur les intérêts privés et
aujourd'hui nous constatons à quel point
la somme des intérêts catégoriels
s'opposent souvent à ce qu'il ya intérêt
général de la france et les françaises
et les français
mais qu'est ce que dit finalement jean
poperen il dit la lutte des classes a
été le moteur de l'histoire et il
constate qu'elle existe encore et en
effet il y a des classes sociales
antagonistes pour marquerez d'ailleurs
qu'un récent sondage rappelle que les
français considèrent qu'ils
appartiennent à une classe de gens peu
près ne demande pas que l'affrontement
de classe deviennent explosif il faut
par conséquent trouver un dialogue entre
les classes sociales qui s'opposent
jean poperen a été un des premiers à
parler d'un compromis en un compromis
social entre le gouvernement et le
patronat pris comme une entité je pense
qu'il a raison de dire ça oui mais à
propos du patronat il ya aussi d'autres
propos d'une autre nature
je parle de ce qu'il a dit et je
voudrais dire qu'il avait crié que quand
ce qui nous concerne nous le
gouvernement nous souhaitons mais j'ai
passé déjà beaucoup de minutes à le dire
nous souhaitons qu'il puisse y avoir
entre les organisations syndicales
ouvrières et patronales
un vrai dialogue
et que l'on retrouve le chemin des
compromis qui sont nécessaires et le
gouvernement a le souci de rassembler
non seulement celles et ceux qui ont
voté pour lui mais celles et ceux des
français qui aujourd'hui
prenant conscience des enjeux et en
dehors de tout esprit partisan accepte
de jouer les chances de la france
je vais devoir vous présenter comme un
homme de dialogue et même un homme de
compromis
vous sentez vous prétendez assurer le
maximum le dialogue la recherche de
compromis
pourtant dans ce sondage ce que vous
citez tout à l'heure ce sondage révélait
aussi qu'une bonne majorité de français
considéraient que les français étaient
moins unis depuis mai 81 qu'est ce que
ça vous fait avoue l'homme de dialogue
et du compromis que je ne crois pas que
cela soit vrai j'ai constaté dans ce
dernier sondage il faudra sans doute que
nous vérifions que l'unique pendant
qu'elle semble je vous parle de noël
sofres l'explosion mais que l'unité les
françaises étaient plus fortes sous
françois mitterrand que ce monsieur
giscard d'estaing que l'aptitude de
françois mitterrand rassembler les
français était plus grande que c'est
marrant mais le constat global c'était
que la vie des français c'était moins
unis eh bien ça veut dire que nous nous
reste travail à faire pour rassembler
les français et le langage que je tien
et celui là vous et je voudrais tout de
même dire deux ou trois choses cet égard
quand l'opposition critique avec sans
retenue le gouvernement quand monsieur
l'abbé demande la démission de françois
mitterrand en oubliant que les
institutions ça existe en oubliant que
les institutions doivent être respectées
il concourt à la division des français
se retrouvent un peu isolé insolence et
oui je ne méconnais pas que monsieur
chirac le désavoue or là je peux
m'interroger l'âme simone veil non
parlons d'abord de monsieur chirac ou
bien monsieur l'abbé monsieur chirac se
partagent les rôles ou bien ils sont en
contradiction sur un point important et
il sera intéressant que nous
connaissions la vérité
madame die par contre effectivement qui
ne ménage pas ses critiques à l'égard de
la politique gouvernement
talent encore qu'elle mettait pas renier
en quelques circonstances car elle a été
là où je suis elle connaît les
difficultés de l'entreprise est à peu
près même chose que vous elle elle dit
par conséquent qu'il ne faut pas
remettre en cause le processus
démocratique normal ceux qui tiennent ce
langage de guerre civile qui appelle au
soutien des manifestations les plus
violentes
concours à la division des français nous
ne suivrons pas sur ce terrain justement
interrogé sur les manifestations tout à
l'heure on vous demandait alain duhamel
vous demandez est ce que l'extrême
droite où l'opposition sont derrière
vous avez répondu pour les étudiants je
pense que c'est l'extrême droite alors
pour les autres les médecins par exemple
l'opposition il a joué un rôle actif
dans l'opposition à appeler en effet au
soutien de la grève des médecins et des
internes et chefs de clinique et à la
grève des étudiants
au dire que après tout elle est sans
doute considère tel dans son rôle
d'opposition mais quand on est confronté
à un problème comme celui de la santé
on n'a pas le droit de jouer avec le feu
voyez vous je voudrais m'attarder un
instant sur ce point si vous le
permettez les difficultés que nous avons
rencontrées dans la médecine dans les
les chu les centres hospitaliers
universitaires viennent de loin savez
vous qu'il y avait en 1950
trente mille médecins en 1970 soixante
mille médecins actuellement 120 milles
et à l'horizon de 1990 150 voire 160
milles cela veut dire que on a laissé
entrer dans le les études de médecine
beaucoup de jeunes et nous ne pouvons
rien faire car le mouvement
disons descendants n'a commencé que
voici deux ans et la plupart des ceux
qui ont exercé les fonctions d'abord et
des grands noms de la médecine
nous on dit depuis plusieurs années ont
dit au gouvernement précédent
il y a là un vrai problème voulez vous y
consacrer vos réflexions et vos efforts
ajoutez à cela que
les français dépensent de plus en plus
pour leur santé chaque français
dépensent actuellement 5300 francs par
an en moyenne naturellement pour sa
santé ajoutez y le développement
technique les équipements qui sont de
plus en plus coûteux et qu'il faut
remplacer souvent parions le scanner
aujourd'hui est une invention
révolutionnaire que beaucoup de dons
beaucoup d'hôpitaux sont vont avoir
et puis dans quelques années il faudra
remplacer ça parce qu'on appelle la
médecine nucléaire et après d'autres
progrès technique donc semaine vont donc
un problème grave et délicat et je
comprends que les étudiants d'une part
que les médecins d'autre part que les
internes et chefs de clinique
s'interroge ce que j'ai rencontrés ils
m'ont souvent interpellé avec énergie
mais en même temps avec un certain
sentiment d'angoissé ils ont dû
manifesté avec violence et je la grève
et je vais entendu non ils ont dû en
effet nous saisir de leurs problèmes
mais ces problèmes il les portaient en
eux depuis plusieurs années et nous
avons ouvert la discussion et j'ai
constaté grâce d'abord aux efforts que
nous avions accompli
alain savary edmond hervé et moi et
ensuite grâce à l'intervention décisive
des médiateurs nous avons pu trouver une
solution et nous sommes en train de en
passe de trouver une solution pour les
étudiants en médecine
c'est pourquoi je crois aux vertus du
dialogue je voulais surtout faire
comprendre aux françaises et aux
français que nous sommes là devant un
problème de société qu'il n'est pas
question question de mettre en cause le
droit à la santé mais qu'il faut tenir
compte
aujourd'hui du fait que la durée de vie
s'allonge que le progrès technique est
là et que la démographie médicale a fait
naître dans les professions de la
médecine
une inquiétude qu'il me faut
naturellement prendre à l' approche des
élections anglaises
on parle souvent dans la presse en ce
moment de l'exemple anglais on entend
par là qu en angleterre sous le
gouvernement travailliste à quelques
années le resserrement des revenus a
provoqué une grande désillusion chez les
cadres chez les chercheurs
j'ai les gens
kiki qui amorce le processus industriel
beaucoup sont partis à l'étranger
beaucoup se sont démobilisés les
ressorts dynamique se sont cassés est ce
que vous ne craignez pas que la
recherche du ce qu'on appelle la justice
sociale plus grande égalité sociale en
france n'aboutisse ou même résultat qui
on l'a vu après en angleterre était
catastrophique
oui vous voulez opposer notre volonté de
réduction des inégalités aux
conséquences qui a pu connaître la
grande bretagne donc pas tellement ça il
ya aussi le natif du de jean fourastié
dans le point cette semaine qui explique
bien que égalité justice
oui ce n'est pas toujours la même chose
j'ai bien compris je voulais si vous
voulez faire un petit raisonnement
lorsque nous parlons de la réduction des
inégalités
nous parlons naturellement de la
réduction des inégalités face à la
distribution du revenu
nous parlons de deux autres formes
d'inégalités qui sont également très
grave
l'inégalité devant l'accès au savoir
devant l'accès aux connaissances devant
l'ouverture à la culture et c'est un des
points très importants pour le
gouvernement
vous avez tout à l'heure entendu ce qu'a
été ma carrière comme l'on dit je sais
ce dont je parle c'est pas toujours
facile d'apprendre à 30 35 40 ans et il
est bon dès le plus jeune âge et dès
l'adolescence d'être mis en mesure
d'acquérir les connaissances disons les
plus importantes
il ya sur ce plan-là dire une réflexion
peut-être un peu plus profonde
je préfère pour ma part des têtes bien
faites
elle était trop plein cela ça nous pose
deux problèmes disons de la réforme de
l'éducation
actuellement en cours de réflexion
et ce qui est admis à l'occasion du
troisième forme de d'illégalité les
inégalités devant l'exercice du pouvoir
et là c'est très important c'est
pourquoi nous avons fait la
décentralisation
c'est pourquoi nous avons ouvert les
entreprises la démo
ainsi il faut que devant le pouvoir le
shaq française chaque français puisse se
sentir associés aux décisions
avoir la possibilité de contrôler les
décisions alors j'en viens maintenant
après avoir peut-être usé d'un trop long
préambule à la question vous nous posez
lorsque nous voulons réduire les
inégalités il ne s'agit pas d'opérer un
événement il faut qu'il y ait des
différences de revenus en fonction de la
qualité du travail rendu ce les
différences de patrimoine me choque
souvent surtout quand elles sont
héréditaires mais que l'on reconnaisse à
chacun ses mérites et qu'ils soient
normalement rétribuer me paraît légitime
nous ne sommes pas partisans d'une
société de nivellement et c'est la
raison pour laquelle lorsque j'observe
aujourd'hui la progression du smic qui
ne se retrouvent pas toujours sur les
salaires des ouvriers professionnels ou
voir spécialisés de qualité je me dis
qu'il ya là une vraie question dont j'ai
d'ailleurs parlé déjà avec les
responsables des organisations
syndicales
nous allons battre et monsieur maïs
maintenant aux questions d evp parce que
je crois que les téléspectateurs
commencent à piaffer parce que si c'est
le deuxième anniversaire de l'arrivée de
la gauche au pouvoir c'est le troisième
anniversaire ce soir de la mort de bob
marley et que nous ne pouvons pas rendre
l'antenne trop tard philippe harrouard
bon beaucoup de questions monsieur le
ministre et des questions très précises
et très concrètes
pourriez vous nous assurez
solennellement qu'il n'y aura pas de
quatrième d'évaluation comme le film
monsieur mauroy avant la troisième le
gouvernement fera tout et je ferai tout
là où je suis pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
quatrième des dévaluations
cela dépend du gouvernement mais cela
dépend aussi des françaises et des
français
aidez nous à gagner la bataille de
l'inflation aider nous-mêmes à faire en
sorte que les prix augmentent de -2 8%
et aidez nous à gagner la bataille du
commerce extérieur et la crise monétaire
ne se reproduira pas autre question le
1er avril une taxe d alcool est entrée
en vigueur sur les alcools de plus de 25
or on sait que l'alcoolisme en france
réside principalement par l'absorption
de boissons d'un degré inférieur alors
sur le sujet très controversé sais pas
si les téléspectateurs souhaite que nous
taxons la bière avec l'hôte action le
vin on peut retenir cette suggestion
pour un examen ultérieur devant le
parlement
mais les rapports les plus savants ont
démontré tout de même que c'était
d'usagé des boissons titrant plus de 25°
tels que apéritifs anisés whisky et
vodka qui entraînait les conséquences
les plus graves
de toute façon la taxe mais voudrait
dire aussi aux téléspectateurs que la
taxe est un moyen de dissuasion mais
comme dans le même temps le gouvernement
a engagé une action de d'information et
qui vise à prévenir
effectivement je suis favorable à une
consommation modérée de tous les alcools
du vin et de la bière
ce qui n'interdit pas d'ailleurs d'en
user de temps en temps ce que je fais
généralement avec plaisir autre question
pourquoi la france at-elle été obligés
d'emprunter 30 milliards à la cee
au lieu d emprunter à une banque
internationale la solidarité européenne
doit jouer
il s'agit et d'un emprunt à long terme
les conditions dans lesquelles cet
emprunt a été souscrit ont été exposés
par jacques delors
mais cet emprunt est relié avec les
besoins de financement que nous
connaissons à cause de notre déficit du
commerce extérieur et j'en reviens par
conséquent à l'essentiel de la bataille
ont déjà parlé 1 la question d'un
fonctionnaire je ne sais pas s'il dépend
de votre ministère mais la question va
peut-être vous surprendre
pourquoi vous comportez vous toujours
comme un super ministre essayez-vous
d'accaparer des attributions ne relevant
pas de votre ministère alors que vous
avez déjà de sérieuses à faire à
résoudre
je ne me comporte pas comme un super
ministre est en tout cas
ni comme un super ministre ni comme un
vice premier ministre on m'a confié la
responsabilité des affaires sociales et
je suis aidé dans cette tâche par
plusieurs secrétaires d'état et par un
ministre délégué je n'ai pas pour
habitude de faire le travail des autres
je suis très bien là où je suis je
permets de préciser quelque chose
d'ailleurs puisque la question avait été
évoquée tout à l'heure au début de cette
émission là où je suis je ne pense pas
du tout à ma carrière je n'ai jamais
programmé ma carrière j'essaie de faire
bien ce que j'ai à faire et si je peut
mériter un jour la reconnaissance des
français pour avoir mené à bien le
dialogue social gens seraient grandement
récompensés et celle de françois
mitterrand d'ailleurs philippe harrouard
oui monsieur le ministre à l'heure vous
avez parlé donc de l'agitation sociale
en france les manifestations
on nous a souvent posé la question
croyez vous à un mais 80 3 qui serait un
mai 68 à l'envers et on nous demande
même est ce qu'il y a une possibilité de
chilly nisation je suppose que c'est que
la france devienne chillida ndfs qu'il
ya risque de convergence entre les
mécontentements actuelle je ne crois pas
à cette hypothèse
je n'y crois absolument pas le
gouvernement a la volonté premier il a
rappelé aujourd'hui de maintenir leur
public
et puis beaucoup de revendications sont
totalement contradictoires
par exemple les agriculteurs ils
manifestent aujourd'hui pour obtenir un
niveau de prix tu es sans cesse discute
à bruxelles et un marc dozier ils
soutiennent l'action de michel rocard
qui se bat en effet pour obtenir un
niveau de prix décent alors lorsqu'il y
à d'autres manifestations
je ne crois pas qu'elle met en cause
l'exercice du pouvoir ni la nature
démocratique de nos institutions
j'observe tout de même quelque chose
c'est qu'il me semble
lorsqu'il s'agit par exemple de telle ou
telle manifestation intéressant des
commerçants que les gros ont
généralement tendance à s'abriter
derrière des petits or je suis partisan
d' ouvrir la discussion sur toutes les
questions qui sont posées
mais il ne faut pas confondre il ya des
revendications légitimes exprimées par
les petits commerçants qui voient
effectivement la transformation des
structures de la distribution avec un
peu d'inquiétude
et puis il y en a qui ne se porte pas
mal donc vous croyez pas au complot
politique au liban voire une dernière
question aurait coûté il y en avait
beaucoup de dernière question mais
peut-être celle ci qui est une femme
retraitée de 75 ans qui a compris en
tout cas les choses ainsi vous dites que
tout va bien monsieur le ministre vous
êtes content faites-vous le marché oui
je fais le marché avec ma femme
disons que c'est elle qui fait le marché
elle me dit d'ailleurs qu'il ya tel ou
tel prix qui augmentent
moi je me contente souvent de porter les
paquets mais je n'ai pas dit que tout
allait bien
peut-être que j'ai naturel optimiste et
que je pense toujours qu'avec de la
volonté on peut résoudre les difficultés
on me prête cette formule quand on veut
on peut
mais je ne mésestime pas du tout la
gravité des problèmes auxquels la france
est confrontée
je voudrais simplement dire à cette
personne que je compte aussi sur elle
pour que la france gagne la partie
et je compte aussi ainsi que le
gouvernement s comme l'a rappelé à
plusieurs reprises françois mitterrand
sur la jeunesse pierre mendès france
avait l'habitude de dire chaque fois que
dans notre histoire
les forces de la jeunesse les forces du
travail
les forces de l'intelligence les
créateurs se sont rassemblés chaque fois
la france a surmonté les difficultés et
a pu reprendre sa marche en avant
c'est de cela qu'il s'agit en ce moment
et ne sous-estime en absolument pas la
gravité des difficultés auxquelles la
france est confrontée
j'assume je souhaite que les français
soient capables de se rassembler autour
du président de la république pour
francs
scheer la passe difficile que nous
connaissons bien c'était l'heure de
vérité de pierre bérégovoy prochain
rendez vous dans quatre semaines bonsoir
[Musique]